hey everybody John Luke and Jordan here
hello and we just got back from the
borderlands 3 gameplay reveal event
we're gonna assume that you've already
seen the presentation they did maybe
you've even seen some of her gameplay so
you know what's new in Borderlands 3 but
we want to talk about how it actually
felt to play four lands three and does
it feel substantial because it has been
quite a while since they've made new
Borderlands I'm gonna say a four years I
want to say since pre sequel and
Borderlands 2 came out in 2012 so it's
been a really long time right and and
pre sequel was like built off the
structure of - which was even in turn
sort of built off the structure of one
this feels more substantially different
I feel like the I thought the weapon
handling overall felt like a little bit
tighter a little bit better they seem
like they've made a lot of improvements
so let's talk about a couple of those
there's sliding and there is mantling
now yes and you can definitely tell when
I spoke to sage the game director he
cited titanfall 2 as one of the
inspiration mechanics and that makes a
lot of sense because you don't go as
fast as titanfall 2 but the mantling and
the sliding just makes the flow of
combat move so much more quickly and it
feels a lot smoother and better to play
this game than previous borderlands
games I definitely had a train my brain
to use it because I've actually been
like replaying Borderlands like 1 and 2
so I'm like Brett I can slide right I
can mantle I'm curious how much I'll
actually end up using those specific
good the slide the mantle I like because
it adds more like verticality to the way
they're designing these levels which i
think is pretty cool we can touch on
that a little bit later but sliding is
neat but at the same time I still found
myself just like bunkering down in
shooting people
yeah but maybe that's just me I would
love for them to maybe tweak the sliding
a little bit apex has spoiled me and I
want it where I can just incidentally
slide around right yeah I kept trying to
slide down slopes and then eventually
this stuff I'm like oh doesn't keep
going but yeah but I do think that is
nice it makes the combat feel faster
which is another thing like everything
feels faster pace than those previous
borderlands games I feel like enemies
are moving around just like the combat
just feels like it's faster over mm-hm
and I'm not entirely sure if it is
actually faster or if it's kind of like
you said how the fact that the
the sliding of man thelema has you to
interact with the environment a little
bit more so enemies are ducking behind
cover they're climbing up on stuff and
you can now do the same so you're moving
a lot more you want Borderlands 3 when
you're fighting people you're not just
kind of like standing on one side of the
battlefield with the enemies on the
other side and just shooting at each
other right that was like a classic
Borderlands strategy especially one was
like the enemies will charge at me so I
will hold back and shoot at them no sort
of like the way you did combat in that
game and it's gotten like more dynamic
over time but this feels like they're
really stepping it up and like you are a
vault hunter you are hunting down the
enemies that you're fighting compared to
the other games I feel like they have
improved it a lot and it feels it feels
pretty good yeah something that didn't
feel as good is the driving portion yes
the game like they've made improvements
for it the vehicles don't flip over as
often but there's still a little too
weightless in my opinion and it's still
not the easiest to get around when
you're driving yeah it is the handling
feels a bit better for sure but I didn't
think the combat was much improved like
it's still that weird thing where
especially when you're playing
single-player the best way to use combat
with the vehicles is to actually like
Park yourself and just shoot at them
like you're actually trying to do that
like dynamic driving around doesn't
really work it's one of those things
that it's not like a deal breaker or
anything I mean right it's just sort of
like okay it's a little bit better but
it's not improved in enough that I as
much as I'd want it to be yeah it's
nothing to write home about but
Borderlands has never really been about
driving yeah I don't think it's gonna
negatively impact my Borderlands
experience and I do like some of the
like this cycle the the cyclone thing
they had that's like cool that is pretty
cool to drive around in it's like a
single one-person vehicle I can't shoot
for [ __ ] with it though no you cannot
but it's great to just get around it has
a very tight turn and when you're
driving in the new plan at the city
planet Promethea meets um yeah
the cycle is perfect for getting around
that city right I like that planet
and because it is like a lot of winding
streets it kinda reminds me of like a
like a halo to like new Mombasa yeah
sort of feel which is pretty cool I like
that a lot and there's I feel like
there's a lot more packed into these
levels it's sort of the thing with
Borderlands 1 & 2 is that the levels
were like really flat but really like
large and at least this particular area
feels very different where it feels like
a lot of winding streets a lot of like
vertical like yeah I had to keep pausing
and looking at the map and like changing
it to like see which level of the city I
was right because I'm like I'm where the
marker is I'm like oh no I'm a level
above the marker I need to go down yes
and they made improvements to the map
which is really nice where it actually
shows verticality mm-hmm and also it
paints where you've been before which Oh
which is really nice because when I got
to the end of the demo and I was like
all right let me look around and see
what I missed I could easily see like oh
I haven't been over there I can go back
so subtle changes like that this map in
particular I really like it it feels
like a place I can explore and and you
know find secrets in which I was able to
find at the end of my demo
yeah and even better it feels distinct
from Pandora I was so worried when they
had had announced that we were gonna be
visiting other planets that they were
just gonna essentially just be Rhys kins
of Pandora but fighting on Promethea
actually felt different like you said
there's a verticality of the
environments there's some long but
narrow streets fighting on this planet
felt different traversing this planet
felt different than Pandora and we have
no idea what the other planets have in
store but this makes me hopeful that
most of the new planets offer different
gameplay experience depending exact
travel to
the other thing is the guns themselves
which is always a big part of
Borderlands the big new thing is the alt
fire like so you know almost every gun
can you can switch it and it'll have an
alternate fire mode it's really weird
when you find a gun that doesn't have
one mm-hmm it's like oh this is just a
normal borderland gun I almost don't
want it because of that right but I I
really like the alternate fires because
I feel like they've used it to encourage
maybe like some of the problems I had
with Borderlands so the big problem I've
always had with Borderlands is the
elemental stuff I never found it it's
useful but when you're trying to spec
for it I usually go for like just the
higher damage right and I happen to have
one has an elemental effect and now with
the alternate fires it's more useful
because there are all sorts of ways
alternate fire can work one of them is
that the gun functions the same beauty
switch which elemental type you're using
and so I when I had a gun like that I
actually found myself being more
strategic and like using those elements
like oh I can switch to the shocked one
and use it on that guy shield and then I
can switch to a different one so that
actually like felt better yeah it
essentially doubles your arsenal because
you've got four guns right have
alternate firing rates and this
essentially then have eight I think it's
gonna really help in the beginning when
you probably can only have one gun
finding one that has an old fire rate
will essentially allow you to start with
- so like stuff like that makes the guns
feel more viable I was mixed on some of
the guns I ended up like there are some
that I really like and some I didn't
like I kept finding a lot of like
shotgun throughout a charge and maybe
that's just my personal preference but I
don't like like it takes like three
seconds to charge the shot and then you
shoot it and then the amount of damage
it did was like not mm-hmm I found one
that was really good but like I had
found like six that were just garbage
before then of like charging shot yeah
like I it's just like there's not it's
not doing enough damage I rather just
get a shock and I can fire normally and
like that feels better but there were
definitely a lot of guns that felt
really good I really liked the Jacob's
guns like like fire as fast as you can
there is one that you like Hand Crank
they've really gone above and beyond and
like making each gun like feel unique
it's animations you know like there's
the one that you pull with like a motor
and yeah I can like pour water on it or
you know use a squirt gun enjoy reduce
it looting a gun feels a lot more like a
deliberate choice like I'm putting
together my ideal loadout that fits the
place that I'm doing with a vault tender
as opposed to just picking up like you
said earlier the strongest gun yeah
available to me I'm trying to actually
find I was like oh this has a really
nice vault fire and the kind of I think
ties into the fact that now with vault
hunters having three different action
skills there's more choice in how you
build the type of vault hunter that you
want to play in Borderlands 3 yeah I
really like all the alternate skills
having tried both characters like Amaya
her thing is like okay well you have
this one ability that's basically just
my ax
my is ability from Borderlands 2 but
then you also have this one where you're
like shooting out this like projected
image of herself which I found very
useful if I wanted to play more
long-range you have this like one that's
like a ground slam if you want to be
more up close so unfortunately because
we didn't have all the skills we didn't
get to like see the full breadth of like
the skill tree yeah there were some at
the bottom I'm like oh that sounds so
cool there's no way I'm gonna earn
enough experience to get there but like
in execution we don't know how those
work but at least the basic skills are
starting with you can tell that they're
putting a lot more effort into making
each character feel more unique or yeah
customizable with that stuff yeah before
it felt like each kind of vault hunter
kind of fell into their own like
distinct role like you could play Maya
however way you wanted to but the fact
of the matter is is she was a crowd
controller because that's what her
ability did and where all of her three
trees kind of were variations of that
singular role this one the vault hunters
kind of feel like they can more easily
build distinctive roles right I feel
like they were starting to get to that
like you had stuff like gauge the DLC
character from Juhu like her skill trees
actually almost made her play like
completely differently yeah so that's
kind of the big takeaway is that
Borderlands 3 isn't necessarily like
reinventing Borderlands but it feels
like they are improving and making good
on a lot of like potential promises that
like Borderlands 2 had yeah okay like
you're improving like mobility and just
like the feel of combat feels like
tighter and better
you're making the environments like more
varied and you're improving on the skill
trees you know it's hard to say whether
if you didn't like Borderlands before if
you're gonna this is gonna change it for
you I don't think it well I don't think
it well this is just more Borderlands
it's more Borderlands but I think the
changes they are making to Borderlands
is really smart and it feels good which
is sort of back when I saw the original
trailer I was worried that it's it just
looks more Borderlands that it wasn't
gonna be that much different but III
think the changes they're making are
really smart and having had a chance to
actually play it it feels good yeah I
will freely admit I was wrong cuz I was
also on that video and I said looks like
it's pretty much the same and I don't
know I feel about that and even though
there are parts of it they're very
similar they have changed enough that I
am a hundred percent back yeah
absolutely
freely doing that we were wrong about
that so thank you for watching our
hands-on impressions of Borderlands if
you want to see more Borderlands I think
Reims like a ton of gameplay and we did
a live stream there you have a bunch of
impressions I believe ya and Steve and
Kevin and Tam helped out by pushing out
a bunch of awesome break outs yes so go
check all of that stuff out and we will
be covering more of Borderlands as they
announce more stuff probably at e3 so
see you guys then bye bye